I'm a die-hard Knicks fan
they've been sorry for a long time I
mean they're staring in a better
Direction but they really pissed me off
at this time Isaiah Thomas was running
the show he was also the basketball
coach
they're sorry
they're just playing horrible
and they go to Boston
and they lose by 45.
I pick up the phone and I'm I'm near
tears
because I know what I'm gonna do
I call Isaiah Thomas and I said
I'm so sorry from the bottom of my heart
I have to call for you to be fired
you have to go
I said it's just too bad you got too
much going on
and I say your personal business is your
personal business but it's so bad right
now you cannot be the coach of this team
and Isaiah Thomas said
my brother
do your job I understand
and when I tell you when I tell you the
level of love to this day that I have
for him for that moment
um I cannot put it into words because
obviously he could have reacted so
differently but it was so bad because he
had so much personal stuff going on that
he knew at that time he probably needed
to go and I remember and then hearkened
me back to what that soccer coach at
Wake Forest that I wrote about in my
book straight shooter Walt chisholwich
was his name he's not deceased as well
he taught me the game of soccer I was an
inspiring reporter and he had some of
the team over I was as an intern and I
was called upon to do this big piece and
he caught the team over and he said I
want you to give him complete access for
the next three days we're gonna teach
him the sport of soccer so he could
write a good feature on us
and and and the article was so good that
the sports editor Terry oberley at the
Winston-Salem Journal back then mate
named me the beat writer for the soccer
team and they were ranked third in the
country
and Walters of which did not like an
article that I wrote and I said what did
I do he said that was a [ __ ] article
he said you didn't tell the truth you
soft
he said you gotta get along with these
players and you're scared to himself he
said you know this defenseman isn't
doing his job you know this Center
didn't do his job you know this goalie
didn't do his job you didn't say it he
said you're not here to be our friend
you're here to call it like you see it
be Humane be respectful be thorough but
call it like you see it you said you
wanted to be a journalist right well
this is how it has to be done
and don't let me tell you that again
hold us accountable and that includes me
that's what he said to me and I forgot
it I got to tell you those two first of
all when you just I just I got tears in
my eyes when you told me about Isaiah
Thomas yeah I mean well oh my God for
him to say to you then you got to go do
your job brother yeah what a man what a
man are you still friendly with them you
talk all the time you talk all the time
I love them daily so he didn't shut down
on you no he didn't no no he said you've
got your job to do and I don't resent
you and he was a lot like Kobe like if
he disagreed with me about saying call
curse me out you know you call cursed me
out whatever we we go back and forth I
like the Knicks I go to the games is
there anything they can do immediately
to become a better team I mean why don't
they ask you yours trust me they asked
me my opinion that's why they mad at me
I don't talk to them right now they
don't talk to me right now because I'm
just really well they they pissed me off
they have a multitude of draft picks
they could have traded them for this
star named Donovan Mitchell he was in
Utah last year
well what do the New York Knicks do
they grab a bunch of people and they go
to a game
where Donovan Mitchell was playing for
Utah and Jalen Brunson who the Knicks
now have is playing for Dallas
and they go to the game looking like
they're recruiting
Howard this is not College it's the pros
right okay so it offended the folks in
Utah
and my sources told me Danny age was
like the last thing I'll do is give them
give them bastards Donovan Mitchell I
don't give a damn what they say and he
sent Donovan Mitchell to Cleveland
I'm saying you have a God that what is a
star in this league he will be an
All-Star this year and here is a guy
that wanted to be a Nick that is from
New York
that was literally packing his bags
looking forward to coming to New York
and you exacerbate the situation
unnecessarily and you don't get him now
Jalen Brunson is going to be an All-Star
as well he's done a great job that was a
great pickup by the New York Knicks he
steadied the ship to some degree from
the point guard position they deserve a
lot of credit in that regard
but my goodness you've got Jalen Brunson
well Leon Rose is the president of
basketball operations for the Knicks
Jalen brunson's father was his first
client
no problem with that Rick brunson's a
great guy but what do you do
a month before you bring Jalen Brunson
you bring his dad this ain't college man
you see what I'm saying it's just a look
it's the Optics of it they do stuff like
this that really shows
other players in the league you're
somewhat Bush League that hurts us we're
quite we're a quality team we'll get to
the playoffs but are we winning the
championship hell no Howard you're
talking about
like not even basketball you're talking
about human beings stuff like stuff you
do as a human being he drives me crazy
about the Knicks that's why I won't go
to the Garden because they pissed me off
and I said you know something I'm gonna
keep my cool because if I go to the
garden now they're gonna do something to
piss me off and I'm gonna go on first
take on ESPN and I'm gonna explode and I
want to do it so I'm doing them a favor
by staying away